how's he's got in trouble  for having a bad day for those of you  that never read the article here's what  happened they got home from dinner she  sat on his kitchen counter and then they  both agreed that he was going to put his  this part  on her this part  immediately when they got home it's like  a kid hitting a ball at little league  and running right to third it's adorable  but there are rules here  then they both agreed that she was going  to put her this part on his this part  two times  gentlemen I think we can all agree that  no means no every single time but then  ladies you also have to agree that no  one can hear you saying no when you  voluntarily put their dick in your mouth  two times  in the article she was quoted as saying  he wasn't getting my non-verbal cues  well where I'm from sucking a dick is  not a good one  and that is not how you call Uber  everybody knows that